[Music]  [Music]  so you need to see this only someone  with Beckett's skill set could pull off  this shot Brandon Beckett is now our  primary suspect now a suit armed and  dangerous let's find them now dad  I've been set up knock knock now if  you're guilty it's gonna get really ugly  but if you're innocent whoever did this  is gonna want to tie up loose Anna  that's not so good either hey  something's wrong I promise you I will  be to the bottom of this  [Applause]  Becket's transport has been attacked his  father Thomas Becket is now a priority  it seems the Sun isn't working alone  okay everyone now let's go we gotta move  sir step away from the vehicle  we got company  take that it's locked and loaded if  she's the shooter the frame he was it  take heard why let's get to work  you're sending my kid in his bait  you better believe I'll be the one  taking that shot  [Music]